tous les délices un dernier au revoir à
2018 mais surtout la dernière chance de
se procurer des chocolats andry la fin
d'une époque pour le chocolat artisanal
concocté à la main à montréal depuis
soixante dix huit ans dans les années 40
toutes étaient rationnés
à cause de la guerre donc les gens à
porter leur ration de sucre de chocolat
ou des choses comme ça et g en étant
juliette c'est comme ça un peu qu'elles
ont commencé par elle même jeu que
londres et c'est donc une histoire de
famille mais surtout une histoire de
femmes les femmes en affaires c'était
parce qu'on voyait habituellement donc
ils ont toujours un puce faire d'où leur
apporter ce n'était pas très bien vu
d'où un peu le nom de la chocolaterie
andrée c'est l'avant drapé du bâtiment
centenaire devenu une charge financière
importante mais aussi le départ à la
retraite de plusieurs employés
essentielles qui ont poussé la troisième
génération de propriétaires a fermé
boutique
si remplie d'émotions mais c'est aussi
très sereine comme comme atmosphère
savait depuis 2009 je travaille ici
alors nous sommes de la famille ici ce
matin je me suis réveillé avec les
larmes ont joué et les clients aussi ont
tous leur souvenir émotif à ce chocolat
particulier moi je suis venu de granby
ce matin justement parce que c'était la
dernière journée
mon père achetait chocolat pour ma mère
dans les années 60 est certes peu près
et puis moi parce que j'ai continué de
ces deux montants achetés à ma mère
c'est une tradition m jeu pour faire des
cadeaux parce que dans notre famille
c'est quelque chose du championnat andré
il n'aura fallu qu'une heure trente pour
que la dernière boîte de chocolats andré
soit vendu preuve de la qualité du
produit
c'est avec passion et amour issigeac
audrey charbonneau raid du canada
montréal